[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i brought in one of my good friends very
very funny comedian thank you for coming
by me yeah of course you know it's
always cool to meet comedians and like
you recognize me yeah you're a
good-looking guy you're successful you
get to have some success and like
somebody knows it or whatever and you're
like okay i'm you know yeah i did
something well yeah
well we have actually a pretty natural
classic
uh archetype comedy dynamic right it's
wacky guy straight guy basically you
know yeah cause you have like you'll
always kind of surprise me with like
your references to like anything i'm
like this dude has deep knowledge about
things i don't expect dude i just have a
big dick
i identify with what you're saying a
hundred percent i i feel the same
as you i feel like a lot of people be
like no way
i know it's very strange and i that's
the thing is when you have a
like a small dick then you look at
what an extreme version of it is and
you're like
that seems pretty awful it's really
really sad that's why it's so great to
meet lesbians they don't care and
they're not yeah wowed by it they're not
influenced by it they don't have any
interest in it right you know this is a
perfect time to segue mm-hmm okay
because like you just gave a bullet
point so this is the thing that they
wouldn't want us to do on the show you
were like let's you're like porn as a
talking like so
did you watch a porn like what's the
porn thing did you watch it yeah yes
i feel like the group setting is a weird
one like i'm a one-on-one or like small
group thing and now you're like i'm
gonna sit on her mouth
i can do it to my wife i could
definitely do it to bert
friend wise i mean there's a couple
other and a couple cousins and stuff
that i'm close with where i would jesus
i wouldn't but there's you know you you
come down a step from that and somebody
where they could be like what are you
doing oh my god that was it huh you see
them again
who else
i'm leaving somebody out oh michelle
obama that's a good one
no that that's pretty good you ever [ __ ]
a [ __ ] before yeah i don't know it
just felt [ __ ] so lame well now
you've like now i'm in a bad mood
about what you're making me do but that
situation is it's hard to yeah cause you
[ __ ] ruined my happiness
because now like now like i'm in a bad
mood now picturing how not fun
your [ __ ] pitch was you know you just
gave a life lesson to me too because i
like when you're saying that
it resonated that is so good that's so
good it's so silly that that it's real
that it's so silly you're right there
are some people where you're like
we all know whatever well you know let's
like the [ __ ] 50 people and you're
like these people like i i don't think
you'll [ __ ] me but i'm not sure like i
want to
and then there are like degrees of
separation it's like i can text this
dude once a month and it's fine right
and you know this person
every week and this person is a phone
call if you have it in your heart [ __ ]
somebody who is disabled yeah exactly
well yeah because you can't do it for
them yeah but you find and i think in in
what we do
you find and i guess this probably
applies to in life i shouldn't say even
but i you we see it and what we do is
that there are people
like
you can't do it for like you can't do it
for them here's the thing it makes me
feel like i feel gratitude
that
the possibility of this is real yeah
because we're like i go like i'm a
comedian and this opportunity you know i
get the question i get i'm sure you've
been asked this question people were
like
who would you like flip out to me and
i'll be like sitting there and i'll go
it's just you let me be there yeah yeah
well there's comedians though that do
things like um like that someone's
opening the show and they bring people
to the green room and you're like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind i'm not
doing it but like how do you not
intuitively know that right you know
like i've seen that like where i'm like
huh the guy brought his family in one
time and i was like what's this he's
like my family i was like what all right
that's it thank you guys for watching
and listening we love you see you next
week absolutely see you guys next
time and tom
one goes topless while the other wears a
shirt tom tells stories in thomps the
machine there's not a chance in hell
that they'll keep it clean here's what
we call
two bears on cave
[Music]
[Music]
you